- Next is Erica Dent,
a second grade teacher
at Joaquin Miller Elementary
in Burbank, California.
Hello. How are you doing today?
- Good, thank you. Thank you.
- [Kelly] So, what's your question?
- Well, hi, Kelly. Hi, Dr. Biden.
- Hello.
- I absolutely love teaching.
I knew from a very young
age that I wanted to teach
when I thought passing out papers
was the coolest thing you could do.
And then, as I grew older,
I knew I wanted to help shape lives.
And it wasn't until my ninth grade year
that I had my first teacher of color.
So, I know the importance
of representation,
but I am concerned.
I know that I feel,
and I'm pretty sure other
educators in the room feel,
that teaching is getting harder.
I know not many people are
entering the profession
and so many teachers are
considering quitting.
What do you think we should
do to be able to keep
this diverse group of teachers
and then also help feel supported?
- So, I think, you know, we
are our own best advocates,
I think, for the profession.
We know how much we love
teaching. It's who we are, right?
And so, I think we are the ones,
we have to be the messengers that go out
and spread the word.
Like, if you're in some
job that you don't like,
come and teach, because
you'll find meaning every day.
You'll find that you can
change someone's life.
And what our administration
is doing, which I love,
is that they are now
paying for apprenticeships.
We're gonna pay you
until you get your teaching certification.
So now, these teaching apprenticeships
are one of the things
that we're aiming for.
Plus, we must have more teachers of color.
(audience applauds)
- And I know that you said
it was important for you
to see someone that
maybe looked like you -
- [Jill] Yeah.
- When you were, but it's
also important for my kid
to see all different walks of life.
- [Jill] Yeah.
- Like that's, I think
that's just as important.
Like, representation isn't
just for one type of person.
It's for everyone to see everything.
That's the important part.
(audience applauds)
Thank you so much.